hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
important concepts in Rainer Maria Rilke
is letters to a young poet is what we
translate in English typically as
solitude in German it's Ines um kite and
another translation for it that you'll
see sometimes used in his poetry is
loneliness because I need some means
being on one's own enzym kite is the
state of being on one's own and for
Rilke this is not just something that
you could say predicate of a person who
happens accidentally to be on his or her
own instead it's something that belongs
to a person that in some respect makes
them the person who they are what they
do with their solitude and he considers
it to be an essential part of the human
condition but it's not necessarily a
feature of that condition that everybody
manages well or understands or reacts to
in the the right ways and every
individual person every human being is
not only capable of solitude of having
some sort of interior aura t an inner
life however you want to put it
something that is their own that makes
them they're the individual who they are
apart from although it could still be
engaged with other individuals
Rilke goes beyond that he actually
suggests that it is absolutely central
to the human condition so in letter 8 he
says to speak of solitude again it
becomes clearer and clearer that
fundamentally this is nothing that one
can choose or refrain from we are
solitary this is what we are we are
lightens up we are on our own to some
degree we can delude ourselves about
this that's a possibility that's a
choice and act as if this were not true
that is all but how much better it is to
recognize that we are alone yes even to
begin from this realization he says and
if we do begin from this realization
it's going to help us over time not
immediately he talks about being dizzy
when thinking about this but it will
help us over time to develop into a
state where we can make use of that that
solitude in an earlier letter number 5
when he is writing to this this young
man he suggests to us that solitude is
is not something that we can actually
avoid in part because he says actually
this is letter 6 rather he says when you
notice that your solitude is vast you
should be happy for what would a
solitude be that was not vast there is
only one solitude and it is vast heavy
difficult to bear now what he's
suggesting there is that we're all
sharing to some degree not just within
this condition that makes us each one of
us isolated and alone by ourselves but
that we're all in some respect together
in this aloneness as well that the
solitude that
I can explore and retreat into or avoid
and try to escape from in me is in some
respect the same solitude that you are
in or that Rainer Maria Rilke nor is
interlocutor is in so he has a very
strong you could say metaphysical
conception of this is being part of the
human condition he also talks about it
in relation to childhood at several
points that's not to say that solitude
only stems from or develops within
childhood but childhood is one period
where we can go back to and remember and
realize that we encountered it and that
we lived within it and if you if you
think about your own childhood however
you know great or traumatic it was there
you're going to find something similar
to what he's talking about he suggests
in his very first letter that his
interlocutor this guy coppice should
withdraw into his his own solitude he
says try to raise up the sunken feelings
of this enormous past your childhood
your personality will grow stronger your
solitude will expand and become a place
where you can live in the Twilight where
the noise of other people passes by far
in the distance and that is you know
coming about because of this this
movement back into childhood he also
talks about a child's attitude towards
adults and he says to be solitary this
is in letter six as you were when you
were a child when the grown-ups walked
around involved with matters that seemed
large and important because they looked
so busy and you didn't understand a
thing of what they were doing when you
realize their activities are shabby
their vocations are petrified and no
longer connected with life why not
continue to look on it as a child would
as if you were looking at something
unfamiliar out of the depths of your own
world from the vastness of your own
solitude and so within childhood
we already have and encounter with with
this now that doesn't mean that we fully
cognizant or understand its value or
even develop our solitude entirely it
depends on our stages of life and
adulthood is going to be important but
childhood is something we can go back to
it solitude should also be understood in
terms of growth and distance and there's
a really a two-fold aspect to this
Rilke talks about solitude itself as
something like interior space that it
can be smaller or it can be larger or
vast or wider he also talks about the
solitude of external spaces for example
when he is writing to Kappas from you
know Russia for example when he's
talking to campus about campus as a
military officer about where he's
stationed out and as we would say the
boonies or the sticks in the midst of
nature particularly when it's you know
wintertime and the snow is falling and
there's nobody else around there's this
this vast external landscape and we can
have something like that within
ourselves
this vast internal place so we can you
talked about our ability to grow
solitude and he suggests as I'm going to
talk about in a moment that we might do
that when things are in fact most
difficult for us when the solitude
itself is hard to bear that's when we
have the opportunity to grow that
solitude but I mentioned this is a
two-fold thing about growth and distance
it's not as if we're just sort of
opening up this space within ourselves
within whatever you want to conceive of
it our heart or mind our narrative we
are ourself growing within that solitude
as well so if we have too small of a
space of solitude not a lot of room for
us to grow we need to have
we need to develop enough space that we
can move around within it and there by
ourselves grow and deepen and even
connect ourselves back out to things you
might say outside of the bounds of our
own little solitude to that of the rest
of the world and to others he stresses
that solitude itself is very difficult
to bear and and it's quite
understandable we don't you know if you
want to translate solitude I'm Tom kite
as loneliness there is a lonely aspect
to it so he cautions campus he says in
the midst of the holiday you're bearing
your solitude more heavily than usual
more with more difficulty right he says
when you notice it is vast you should be
happy and this is where we have this
previous quote what would a solitude be
that was not vast and he says it is vast
heavy difficult to bear and almost
everyone has hours where he would gladly
exchange that solitude for any kind of
sociability however trivial or cheap for
the tiniest outward agreement with the
first person who comes along the most
unworthy but perhaps these are the very
hours during which solitude grows its
growing is as painful he says as the
growing of boys and as sad as the
beginning of spring but this must not
confuse you what is necessary after all
is only this solitude vast inner
solitude to walk inside yourself and
meet no one for hours that is what you
must be able to attain and that's
something that can be quite difficult
for many of us at you know many points
in our life he also writes a little bit
later this is in letter seven don't let
yourself be confused in your solitude by
the fact that there is something in you
that wants to move out of it he suggests
that if you use this desire prudently
you will in fact be able to expand that
solitude as well but there's this this
drive to get away from solitude
to lose ourselves in something where we
can have some easy agreement some some
superficiality some convention with
another person he also talks about you
know in some very important ways the
relationship between solitude and love
and I think this is a particularly
important thing to keep in mind because
you might think about solitude as
something that you have just by yourself
you could say well you know there is
this common human condition of solitude
but we're all these isolated monads you
know or individuals and atomized he's a
phrase that that sociologists
particularly like and none of us have
anything really in common none of us can
see into each other we're all sort of on
our own you come into this world alone
you die alone you live alone right well
that's not that's not the way Rilke
views solitude when solitude is used
correctly in order for us to grow when
we expand it when we are patient with it
it creates the possibility for us to
open up to another person and also to
see them as a person who has their own
solitude in which they have to grow we
don't have to be on top of them all the
time we don't have to be identical with
them we don't have to share everything
with them it's okay if they go off and
read their book or have their hobby and
do their thing over here and don't tell
you about it until they choose to
because that's what it means to have
actual human beings living with each
other it's not sharing everything all
the time but it's not being totally
closed off with each other either and in
letter 7 this is where he talks about
this the most and he says some very
important things here he tells us that
that you know solitude is difficult and
he tells us that love itself ties in
with solitude he says that learning time
is always a long secluded time
therefore loving for a long time ahead
and far out into life is what solitude a
heightened and deep and kind of
aloneness for the person who loves when
you love somebody else you really love
them you are in some respect on your own
loving doesn't mean pushing a button and
getting it the same response from them
and he goes on and he says that you know
it's it's a high inducement for the
individual to ripen to become something
in himself to become world to become
notice what he says here world hidden
himself for the sake of another person
when you love somebody else
you become if you do this more so that
you have more to offer them and you have
to do that by developing this solitude
within yourself you know we often to
have this trivial thing you have to love
yourself before you can love anybody
else this would be really loving
yourself developing what is good for you
this solitude so that you actually have
that to share with another person so
that when they withdraw and and you know
need some time to come back you're not
chasing them all the time and pressuring
them so that you're not saying dumb
stuff just to fill up the air with a lot
of nonsense so that you know there's
there's no quiet spaces or anything like
that you have to grow in order to be
capable of love and he talks about
temptations particularly for those who
he says are young but this would apply
to many older people who never develop
that solitude either who live lives that
are in some respects you know the the
proverbial lives of quiet desperation
right they can't be on their own so they
can't really be with another person
because they think that they're gonna
fuse with them and everything is going
to go great from that point on and Rilke
talks about them as throwing away their
solitude in doing that which is a big
problem comes back damaged unusable he
also has this very wonderful phrase
has been often discussed where he says
that what love would in fact really be
is in the highest degree is this two
solitudes protects and border and greet
each other and I think that it's
important he doesn't just say two
solitudes protect each other two
solitudes you know greet each other two
solitudes border each other
those three things those three elements
all need to be there because each of
them serves an important purpose they
protect each other they take care of
each other including protecting them the
other from themselves from imposing too
much or demanding too much of the other
they border the other they don't fuse
with the other they don't become one
single being they are they are two
different people but they border each
other in a way that other people don't
and they greet each other they have
something to say they have a positive
relation towards each other
Rilke is talking about romantic love in
this case but I don't see any reason why
that couldn't apply just as much to say
friendship or other types of
relationships perhaps inter familial
relationships as well the last thing
that I want to stress here is that Rilke
also views the solitary person as a sort
of path maker they are able to do things
that he thinks other human beings will
eventually be capable of if if humanity
does continue to develop but for the
moment this is something that that is
going to be restricted to the solitary
person he says he's talking about bodily
delight for example and he says people
have kind of screwed this up even with
eating and then he says the individual
can make these deep simple needs of life
clear for himself and live them clearly
not the individual who is dependent not
individuals taking their cues from say
the culinary industry or you know the
food channel or you know popular trends
about food or anything like that but the
person who's actually using their
solitude as a basis for having their own
experiences and thinking about things he
says not the individual who is dependent
but the solitary person the solitary
person has a scope of freedom that other
people do not and they can do things
that other people can't at this time a
little bit later he says everything that
may someday be possible for many people
the solitary person can now already
prepare and build with their own hands
which make fewer mistakes therefore love
your solitude and try to sing out with
the pain that it causes you because that
solitude provides you with this this
this freedom that other people don't yet
enjoy a freedom which allows you to
grasp things and take on tasks that
they're not up to so solitude runs
throughout all of these letters it's
absolutely central to Rilke as vision of
what it means to be a human being what
it means to develop and what it means to
live the good life particularly as an
artist
you